how was your morning when you checked
your bank balance was it correct or
where some debits duplicated when you
shopped online where the stock levels
accurate or were they advertising goods
that were sold out did the website cope
with the traffic and were your details
secure was your train to work on time or
was it delayed even though the screen
and the station didn't show problems our
lives both online and offline revolve
around data which drives the world's
businesses and must be protected at all
time data moves via mainframes Linux or
Windows servers and other platforms
on-premises and in the cloud IBM MQ
powers thousands of businesses worldwide
invisibly moving terabytes of data
making your world work for you
MQ sends your payments once and once
only avoiding costly duplications MQ
connects applications and systems in
different places so you can make
purchases and the retail stores and head
offices can always keep track of
business MQ handles billions of messages
so websites are running when you expect
them to be even during peak periods and
MQ encrypts those messages which can
contain your personal information
wherever they are so that you can feel
secure and your access to applications
is uninterrupted thanks to MQ seamless
high availability with MQ you know about
train delays because those station
boards across the whole railway network
are updated in real-time and at the same
time so that you have the right
information for your journey home
you